how many different species or kinds of
birds are there take a guess
100 1000 more
well biologists have estimated that
there are at least 10 000 different
species of birds all around the world
and some biologists think that there are
even more up to 18 000 different species
birds are incredibly diverse think about
the differences between an eagle a
parrot a hummingbird a duck and a
penguin some of them are small and some
are big
and take a look at the differences in
their beaks or bills and their feathers
and not all of these birds can fly
either penguins use their wings like
flippers to swim underwater
collectively these 10 000 plus different
species of birds are product of
evolution which is the change in
heritable traits that occurs in a group
of organisms over many generations
but what are these heritable traits
exactly
heritable traits are those that are
passed from parents to offspring via
genes and they include things like the
colorful patterns and plumage or the
webbing or toes and claws of bird feet
and even though offspring inherit traits
from their parents and look pretty
similar to them
over many many generations these
heritable traits can change
evolution is made possible by genetic
variation or differences in genes within
a population
genes are passed from parents to
offspring and they affect how an
organism develops how it functions and
even how it looks
genes can come in different forms or
alleles which can lead to different
versions of a trait for example in city
pigeons also called rock doves which you
might see flying around different
alleles cause different eye colors such
as orange black and white genetic
variation causes organisms within a
population to have a range of traits
like differences in plumage or eye color
genetic variation can come from lots of
different sources one of which is
through sexual reproduction this type of
reproduction causes offspring to have
different sets of traits compared to
their parents because they receive
genetic material from both of their
parents in other words the offspring
aren't an exact genetic copy of either
parent
in this example of rock doves parents
carry different alleles that affect
their plumage
and in turn their offspring can inherit
different sets of traits and may look
quite different from their parents
now let's take a look at that dove
example with the plumage differences and
think about it at the population level
with lots of doves
you can imagine that those plumage
traits can change over many many
generations of parents and offspring in
a large population
you might see new traits appear like
different colors or different patterns
and feathers
or existing traits like dark colors may
become more or less common
when this type of change occurs or any
change in heritable traits that group of
organisms has evolved
over many generations small differences
in traits between generations can add up
and over time over thousands to millions
of years
evolution can give rise to new types of
organisms
for example over many generations one
population can evolve into two different
species like the rock dove and the hill
pigeon
even though these two types of birds
look pretty similar to one another they
are distinct species that have been
changing along independent evolutionary
paths for about a million years
over the billions of years that life has
existed on earth evolution has given
rise to the amazing diversity of
organisms on our planet
we have over 10 000 species of birds
alive today and there are even more bird
ancestor species that once existed
ancestors that were literally dinosaurs
but that's a topic for another video